now let's go to something that is very
very good for trump this is genuinely
scary
the pennsylvania gubernatorial race also
had its primary yesterday now on the
democratic side running unopposed is the
state's attorney general josh shapiro a
relatively unremarkable democrat
smart from everything i've seen
likeable
perfectly reasonable uncontroversial guy
just normal guy would be a normal
governor on the other side on the
republican side the winner of the uh
gubernatorial primary is a guy named
doug mastriano who pretty easily won
with a 24 point margin over the second
place candidate lou barletta doug
mastriano is an extraordinarily
dangerous weaponized conspiracy theorist
trumpist
who was in washington dc at the capitol
on january 6th who has promulgated
so-called stop the steel conspiracies
who has played coy with q anon
phraseology
and remember that the governor appoints
the secretary of state the person in
charge of running pennsylvania's
elections
uh this is really scary stuff really
really scary stuff
um two we have this interesting uh
report about masteriano two days before
the capitol riots mastriano said he was
heading to washington dc and calling out
to god for divine revelation he used
campaign funds to charter six buses to
shuttle followers to dc and told them he
would speak on the capitol steps around
one o'clock rioters broke into the
capitol some wielding bibles jesus 2020
signs an appeal to heaven flags and
shofars we'll get back to shofars on the
senate floor one insurrectionist called
out from the day is jesus christ we
invoke your name
and of course you know the rest of uh of
what happened on january 6th so this is
a wacky guy he was there for the stop
the steel rally ahead of the riots he
tried to conduct one of these arizona
style partisan reviews of the election
results in pennsylvania he made debunked
conspiracy theory claims about the
election
a sort of centerpiece of his campaign in
pennsylvania he was going to speak at a
q anon branded con conference called
patriots arise in june of 21 ended up
not doing it because of the chaos in the
media that was generated from the news
that he would be speaking there and the
republicans know it's really big that
masteriano won rudy for example was
celebrating it posting i think this was
on truth social rudy giuliani writing
tonight the biggest win
is doug mastriano in pennsylvania he's a
veteran an historian and a true patriot
the most important quality in this
election is guts to destroy the democrat
express train to marxism and the rhinos
who enable it so the press will write
nice things about them doug will be to
pennsylvania what trump was for the
united states and he's not wrong they
are putting the insurrectionists inside
the house
masteriano is disgusting here's one
wacky video back in um january
when mastriano announced he was running
they opened the event
with the blowing of a shofar now i don't
know how many of you know what a shofar
is a chauffeur is a ram's horn it's an
element of the jewish faith and it's
used uh to signify sometimes the sabbath
uh sometimes the end of the fasting
period at yom kippur and there's
actually a history of masteriano
misusing uh jewish symbols this was the
start of the campaign from
this people
i believe god
is about
to manifest himself brother
he has to because we cannot keep going
the way we're going
amen
[Music]
dear god
[Music]
okay
so uh masteriano is not jewish and he
has this history of misusing jewish
symbols as campaign props back in april
he spoke and raised money at a far-right
christian conference called patriots
arise for god and country
and they promoted conspiracy theories
including
the existence of a global cabal of sex
trafficking democrats you guys have
heard this stuff before 911 was a false
flag vaccines are genocide therapy
adolf hitler faked his death and uh once
again jewish organizations criticized
that for the improper use of campaign
props they also used a shofar there so
this is a disgusting guy and he's a
dangerous guy
the 2024 election
could come down to pennsylvania and if
doug mastriano gets to decide who runs
that election it's a really really bad
thing so pennsylvania is becoming a
major area of focus
we should support josh shapiro for
governor we should support john
fetterman for senator now the good news
is for now that recently democrats tend
to win the governorship in pennsylvania
so if we look at some recent elections
in 2018 the democrat tom wolf won easily
by 17 points in 2014 the democrat tom
wolf won easily by about nine points in
2010 a republican did win tom corbett
won by about nine points but then in 20
2006 ed rendell ran away with it with a
21-point win so the hope is
that it's just an overwhelming
democratic gubernatorial victory in
pennsylvania if not
we're really up for it and there's many
different important races
months ago we said pennsylvania will be
a focus pennsylvania's gubernatorial
race is quite literally a referendum on
democracy this is as big as any other
issue just
do you support a democratic system and
if you do you've got to vote for josh
shapiro and if people are looking to
phone bank in a particular race that is
a race that is of significant interest
meanwhile one bit of good gubernatorial
news from yesterday
far right idaho gubernatorial candidate
janice mcgeechen
uh maybe is pronounced mcgeekn i don't
know
she lost in idaho and that is a very
good thing so initial results a mixed
bag
many more primaries coming next tuesday
six days from today and of course we'll
be covering all of it live and just a
quick reminder monday memorial day we're
doing a one-day membership special we
are blowing members we might run out of
memberships okay we are going to offer
an incredible discount off of
memberships on our website our primary
funding source on monday memorial day if
you want to be notified of how to get
the discounted membership just get on my
newsletter at davidpakman.com
i'm really excited that one of our
sponsors today is helix sleep i sleep on
a helix mattress at home i absolutely
love it and that's why i reached out to
them about sponsoring the david pakman
show
buying a mattress in the past
was always a huge guessing game for me i
didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like but helix
has a sleep quiz on their website you
tell them your body type your sleeping
position your back pain issues you might
have and their tool matched me with a
mattress that is perfect for me it's
cool enough at night it's the right
firmness i generally just do way better
sleeping these days because of the
mattress helix was awarded number one
best overall mattress for the last two
years by both gq and wired magazine it
is well deserved i can tell you
firsthand every helix mattress comes
with a 10-year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights and they will even come pick
it up at your house if you don't love it
but i know you will for a limited time
helix is offering up to 350 off all
mattress orders plus two free pillows at
helixsleep.com
pacman it's the biggest discount they've
ever offered the link is down below